i want to do this next story today
because it's important to do
but i want to be careful about the
message that i send to you and i have
something that i'm going to admit to you
which is that donald trump's mishandling
of coronavirus
has pushed me to be as close to a
prepper as i
as i have ever been now preppers are
those who believe
that there is a catastrophic disaster or
emergency
that is likely to occur in the future
and they make
active preparations for it typically
they stockpile
food sometimes they stockpile weapons
and ammunition they stockpile elements
of medical
as you may have come to know them and a
whole bunch of other supplies
and there's a political bent to prepping
so you've got just
general people who general preparedness
advocates who often are not
super politically entwined with the
movement but very often preppers
are small government conservatives
they're prepping because they have a
fundamental distrust of government
sometimes they even have conspiracy
theories about government
that lead them to prep sometimes you
have religiously motivated prepping
mormons for example often do long-term
food storage as a part of their
religion now i am not literally becoming
a prepper i'm not buying guns for
example i'm not buying a year of food or
anything like that
but there is no doubt that the degree to
which donald trump has been completely
untrustworthy and dishonest and
incompetent day in
and day out when it comes to the
coronavirus pandemic
has proven to me not that i need to have
a fundamental distrust of government
and therefore i should be prepping but
that the country is dumb enough to elect
people this poorly suited to manage a
crisis and i do need to be more prepared
it's healthy to have a skepticism of
government's ability to solve every
problem
and i've never trusted government in
certain areas
so for example i've never trusted
government to do foreign policy
correctly
right democrats and republicans we have
hundreds of years of history to
vindicate us on that look at the middle
east
look at latin america look at so many of
these other things
that was always an area where i was very
skeptical
of government part of it is the people
that we elect
to lead us i've never really trusted
government to do criminal justice
correctly look at the war on drugs look
at mass incarceration look at cannabis
look
all these different things but i have
mostly believed
that in a time of real crisis like a
pandemic i consider the coronavirus
pandemic to be one of those instances
i mostly believe that the government
would pull it together and
cross party lines and put ignorance and
politics
and partisanship aside and just take
care of things and yet as
60 000 americans have died 61 000 really
as we continue to find 15 20 25 000 new
cases of the virus every single day
as we clearly are yet not yet doing
nearly enough testing
donald trump has failed he's failed to
be proactive
every day he is going out in gaslighting
as thousands of people were dying on
monday
trump was publicly bragging about how
great everything he's done is
on tuesday as thousands of people were
continuing to die he went out and he did
a complete propaganda press conference
using people with cognitive disabilities
as props to brag about how he and ivanka
have saved the economy
as 30 million people now have lost their
jobs
tens of thousands of businesses have
been unable to get money from that
ppp program because huge corporations
took a ton of cash and the money ran out
so then i start to go to a dark place
our testing rate is
41st in the world and trump is bragging
we've done the most
tests we have the best tests it's total
gaslighting and they can't be trusted
so how does this get me to prepping
while i was thinking yesterday imagine
that we weren't dealing with a viral
pandemic for a second
imagine that the crisis was a bad actor
had poisoned the water supply in urban
areas
and the water was killing people
someone poisons the water supply people
start to die we figure out what it is
the water supply has been poisoned okay
people can't drink tap water anymore
until it gets sorted out but people need
water to live
trump is the type of guy who would have
a slow response
but would insist everything is fine he'd
say just run the tap
we're going to run the taps and
everything's going to be fine it'll
clear out
as people start to die not only from
drinking tainted water but also dying of
thirst
he would go on tv and he would say the
national guard has distributed tens of
millions of gallons
more than any government has ever done
who even heard of distributing 10
million gallons before
and people would be dying because 10
million gallons of water is nothing in a
country of 300 million
and 10 days would go by and there would
still be too little water much like
there are still too few tests and trump
would go on tv and say
hey here's 10 ceos who have developed
great water filtration devices
we've given them a ton of cash of course
huge cash cow for them
they're making money and we're going to
roll out a hundred thousand water
filtration kits to communities and we're
winning and people would be dying of
thirst
and when the hundred thousand filtration
kits show up six weeks later it's not
enough
now i am not someone who has distrusted
government
to effectively take care of some of
these basics
because i never imagined we'd have
someone so dishonest and so immoral in
the oval office but unfortunately
enough americans voted for it in 2016
and that's what we have
so i admit i've been buying more medical
supplies
i've been buying a water filtration
capability i bought some of those
water storage bricks waiting for them to
arrive
and i'll constantly keep you know 15
gallons of water for myself and another
15 gallons for my girlfriend
i've bought more non-perishable food
some supplies if electricity was out for
say
three days everything from you know
waterproof matches
to who knows what i've sort of gone down
down the rabbit hole so i'm sort of
cautiously not for the reasons that the
right wingers
who are preppers do it but cautiously
acquiring
stuff because i never imagined the
voters would do something
like put a donald trump in charge am i
crazy
if anybody else is feeling this way let
me know and i know that there will be
right wingers who say
david you you've taken the red pill you
are now one of us
no no no my my reasons for doing this
are not
small government conservatism or uh
sovereign citizen
ideology or any of that stuff it's wow
the american people might elect a [ __ ]
like this again
and he could or she could once again
fail us that's why i'm doing it
let me know your reaction let me know
what you think i'm on twitter
at d pacman